l'innovation
qu'est-ce que donc l'innovation
ce que je vous propose aujourd'hui c'est
de découvrir ce terme effectivement un
peu obscur parfois au travers d'exemples
dans lequel nous allons pouvoir mener
l'enquête
nous allons regarder sur ces différents
exemples où se cachent l'innovation
elle va vous paraître à certains moments
évidente et je vous démontrerai qu'elle
n'était pas là où je voulais vous
emmener et à d'autres endroits mais vous
la verrez pas et je vous ferai découvrir
comment en fait on est capable de
découvrir l'innovation et de générer de
l'innovation tous autant que nous sommes
donc pour démarrer cette enquête on va
prendre un peu de hauteur et on va
regarder ce qui se passe dans le dans
l'espace avec les satellites les
satellites vous les connaissez tous ils
servent à différentes choses dans
notamment à observer la terre et un
phénomène qui nous inquiète un petit peu
tous en ce moment et depuis plusieurs
années c'est le changement climatique
changement climatique et ses impacts et
les satellites ont la faculté de
surveiller tout ce qui se passe autour
de la Terre tout le temps
l'activité que j'ai menée avec mes
équipes d'innovation ça a été de se dire
mais aujourd'hui on a beaucoup de
technologies à notre disposition on a
beaucoup de savoir
comment peut-on faire pour aider les
gens à réaliser le problème qui nous
entoure dans quelle mesure ils peuvent
influer sur ce phénomène est-ce que
réellement ils en sont correspondables
ou pas du tout
et en fait comment finalement se
positionner dans tout ce que l'on entend
qui peut être de différents niveaux de
différents de différentes cultures de
différentes géographies donc avec
vraiment des problèmes sociétaux qui
peuvent être différents
avec objectif sur la cop26 à Glasgow
l'an dernier
au travers de la société dans laquelle
je suis qui gère de la donnée de la
cybersécurité etc on s'est dit ben voilà
on a on a accès à cette donnée spatiale
comment peut-on faire pour aider des
organismes de type Nations unies à aider
justement mieux communiquer vers les
gens vers nous tous et faire en sorte
que cette information soit prise en
compte et servent vraiment de
base finalement à cette problématique ou
on peut toujours être sceptique
interrogatif ou très convaincu voilà
apporter vraiment une position un petit
peu neutre dans cette problématique là
surtout en regardant mais ce qui se
passe autour de nous et en le constatant
donc on a développé une application qui
aujourd'hui est accessible par tout le
monde dans le monde entier sur
smartphone et tablette
il n'y a pas d'innovation là dessus
le satellite peut être aussi
l'innovation c'est pas forcément le but
de ma présentation mais c'est vraiment
de se dire comment les gens qui vont
utiliser une application vont comprendre
ce qu'il y a à l'intérieur donc
aujourd'hui on peut tous télécharger des
applications n'importe quand
le gros enjeu était de se dire comment
on passe quelque chose qui est mondial
en termes de données il y a de la
mathématique il y a de la science
spatiale il y a il y a du calcul
informatique il y a tout un tas de
choses très complexes qui qui que l'on
utilise et je veux en même temps toucher
quelqu'un qui est au Bangladesh en
Afrique du Sud en Amérique du Nord au
Canada de la même façon avec des règles
qui lui sont propres de compréhension
dans son environnement social
donc toute l'innovation que l'on a
essayé de porter là c'est de se dire
mais
on va arriver à porter la donnée auprès
de tout le monde donc on a effectivement
innové sur le processus qui permet de
passer de donner mondiale à de la donnée
facilement utilisable sur internet avec
une très grande fluidité donc là on
parle de volume de données qui sont
extrêmement importants et en même temps
comment va-t-on être sûr que les
personnes que l'on va toucher vont
comprendre les données qu'on va leur
apporter parce qu'en fait c'est ça
l'objectif c'est pas l'application c'est
pas le satellite c'est vraiment la
donner comme à transporter auprès des
gens et donc là on s'est posé la
question de la communication du
marketing du commerce bien sûr de la
science mais ça vous l'avez déjà compris
ça faisait déjà partie de l'état des
lieux et donc on a vraiment mis le
travail d'innovation sur la
représentation des données leur couleur
leur vitesse d'affichage leur taille
aussi en fonction de la taille d'un pays
d'une région etc et ça a donné naissance
à une application que vous voyez là qui
est sur un donc tablette et smartphone
et qui permet effectivement au quotidien
quand on en a envie de jouer avec la
pollution atmosphérique pour se rendre
compte sur plusieurs années mais ce qui
se passerait réellement chez moi au
dessus de chez moi au-dessus de ma tête
comment les gars ça est fait de serre
sont émis est-ce qu'ils sont émis de
manière homogène autour de la Terre s'il
y a des pays qui émettent plus que
d'autres
on entend toutes ces informations au
quotidien et effectivement on n'a pas
forcément de d'éléments probants qui
nous permettent nous de se la propriété
donc c'était vraiment cet objectif qui
était derrière cette cette application
là donc l'innovation là-dessus c'est
vraiment
se poser la question d'une haute
technicité scientifique d'une haute
technicité technologique ne suffit pas
en fait dans ce processus d'innovation
il fallait vraiment aller au bout de la
logique et ce et remettre en question
des modes de distribution de la donnée
des modes d'accès à cette donnée là pour
se mettre à la portée des gens à la
portée de des explications qui sont à
l'intérieur de manière à obtenir le but
recherché c'est communiquer et avoir une
prise de conscience de la part des gens
qui l'utilisent à leur mesure et on
n'aime pas cette prise de conscience
donc typiquement cette relation là est
aujourd'hui en discussion avec les
Nations unies pour pour avoir vraiment
une communication très large au niveau
de la terre pour cet accès à une
information neutre de toute information
politique sociale et autres lobby divers
et variés
donc vous l'aurez compris l'innovation
elle est faite par des jambes pour des
gens souvent elle est pas isolée dans
son coin et elle appartient à un
ensemble plus complexe que simplement ce
pourquoi on l'a fait
donc au travers des deux prochains
exemples qui vont avoir un lien un lien
je vais vous expliquer comment
effectivement sur des problématiques qui
du coup sont des conséquences du
changement climatique en l'occurrence la
gestion des réserves d'eau douce
eau douce qui sert pour boire au
quotidien pour se laver pour toutes les
activités humaines industrielles pour
les animaux pour l'irrigation de
l'agriculture
et l'eau c'est également une
problématique de sécurité quand il pleut
vous entendez souvent mais il y a des
inondations donc les ouvrages de barrage
et autres retenus rendre dans toute
cette politique à la fois de production
d'eau potable de production
d'électricité aussi il y a des il existe
beaucoup de barrages hydroélectriques
donc on a été sollicité sur la
problématique de la gestion de cette eau
d'abord pour des problèmes de production
hydroélectrique en gros vous voyez la
problématique aujourd'hui qui que l'on
subit aussi c'est la production
d'électricité le but c'est de pouvoir la
produire quand on en a besoin et de
manière potentiellement disponible tout
le temps dans dans la journée dans la
semaine dans l'année sauf que l'eau vous
le voyez il y a des années où il y en a
beaucoup des années où il y en a pas etc
donc il faut pouvoir gérer cette ce
stock d'eau pour l'alimentation pour la
production hydroélectrique
donc notre proposition pour les grandes
producteurs d'électricité a été de leur
dire mais on va encore une fois se
retourner vers l'espace et on a accès
aujourd'hui à des satellites qui
permettent de voir des pays entiers des
continents en quelques jours on a des
satellites qui repassent sur toutes les
parties de la terre à moins d'une
semaine donc on a une capacité à vous
donner une photographie contiellement
continuellement actualisée des contenus
de ces barrages sans forcément les
équiper partout puisqu'il y a des pays
qui sont très bien équipés il y en a
d'autres qui ont aucun équipement il y a
des pays qui se posent la question de
s'équiper ou vais-je construire les
nouvelles les nouveaux barrages etc
la problématique et donc très vite
puisque c'est un problème qui est urgent
on peut pas attendre 30 ans pour pour
régler le problème de l'accès à l'eau
douce pour les gens autour de la Terre
donc il faut agir vite donc il faut
proposer des solutions qui vont vite en
termes d'état des lieux et donc le
satellite encore une fois apporte
énormément de solutions
dans le métier de la gestion de l'eau
notamment des réserves d'eau il arrive
souvent en fait que l'on déplace l'eau
d'un barrage à l'autre donc ça c'est
voilà c'est une pratique assez classique
il y a des canalisations entre les entre
les différents lacs et on délaisse
certains pour en recharger d'autres de
manière à avoir toujours des niveaux
d'eau qui sont suffisants pour tous les
tous les paramètres que j'ai cités
préalablement
mais le problème c'est que
cette eau n'est pas consommé
uniformément sur les territoires il y a
des territoires on irrigue plus à
certaines saisons il y a d'autres
endroits où on a besoin d'eau et puis un
phénomène comme on contrôle pas c'est la
pluie elle tombe un peu là où elle veut
et le changement climatique en plus
attendant ça dérégler un petit peu tout
ça là où il pleuvait peut-être beaucoup
les années passées il arrive des années
où il pleut plus donc il faut être en
capacité d'anticiper tous ces éléments
là pourquoi parce que l'eau c'est lourd
ça se déplace pas facilement c'est pas
comme de la donnée sur internet donc il
faut pouvoir anticiper décharger l'eau
là où on en a pas trop besoin parce
qu'il y en a beaucoup et la mettre là où
là où on en a besoin donc ça c'est un
problème de constatation donc on a
finalement dérivé des usages de
l'observation de la Terre par satellite
pour le focaliser sur une problématique
particulière qui est simplement
mesurer l'altitude des lacs en continu
et permettre surtout et on revient sur
l'approche précédente comment les
utilisateurs de ces données là de cette
compréhension vont être en capacité de
comprendre la donnée qu'on leur fournit
de manière à pouvoir faire leur travail
tout simplement donc c'est un petit peu
ce que vous avez dans l'animation qui
est en bas
en fait on a des règles qui permettent
de d'indiquer quand un lac est en train
de baisser quand un autre ne baisse pas
et derrière ça mais ça permet de dire
bah celui-là ne descend pas ça veut dire
qu'on s'en sert pas donc on va déplacer
l'eau bref vous comprenez la logique
relativement simple donc voilà la
l'innovation mais vraiment de de se
poser la question comment je vais
simplifier quelque chose qui existe déjà
pour l'amener à résoudre un problème
simple mais qui reste complexe d'un
point de vue technologique donc là par
contre on a vraiment mis l'accent sur
quel est le métier de l'exploitant de
celui qui gère l'eau parce que pour lui
proposer une solution il faut être
capable de le comprendre et donc là
dans mes équipes on est plutôt des
informaticiens et il a fallu qu'on fasse
rentrer dans les équipes des gens qui
comprennent la problématique de de l'eau
et nous accompagner sur comment je
traite la donnée pour que quelqu'un qui
en a besoin en termes de métier puisse
l'utiliser
on était plutôt sur le constat mais
comme je vous le disais l'eau c'est
aussi prévoir
prévoir soit avec des moyens que vous
voyez lors des spots météo à la télé ou
sur d'autres supports c'est les
satellites météo c'est les stations
météo de Météo France et d'autres
instituts de prévisions météorologiques
c'est aussi les données qui sont issues
des instituts climatologiques c'est ceux
qui analysent la donnée sur un très long
terme la donnée climatique sur un très
long terme pour pour analyser les
changements saisonniers
donc la problématique là c'est vraiment
de se dire comment je peux aller au-delà
de la problématique de départ qui est je
veux mieux gérer mes lacs c'est aussi
comment je vais prévoir les futurs
pluies qui vont arriver les futurs fonte
de neige etc donc là on s'est posé la
question on n'a pas forcément tout à
notre disposition comment aller chercher
des acteurs qui travaillent dans ces
domaines là pour les associer à notre
dynamique de départ et faire en sorte
que au-delà du constat que je vous
présentais précédemment on soit vraiment
dans la prévision et donc on a intégré
un certain nombre d'approches qui
fonctionnaient déjà et on les a mis à
disposition à niveau par rapport à la
technicité des produits que l'on avait
déjà élaboré de manière à ce que cette
pluie ces prévisions de pluie soit
anticipé de manière assez floue pour les
trois quatre mois à venir et que plus
l'instant présent se rapproche plus on
utilise des technologies qui sont à
temps quasi en quasi temps réel comme
les satellites radar sol etc qui eux
sont capables de prévoir deux heures
avant une pluie qu'elle peut arriver à
tel endroit et en telle quantité et donc
ça c'est primordial pour avoir le temps
minimum minimum et lié au niveau de
risque d'abord le temps minimum de vider
un petit peu les lacs pour en remplir
d'autres pourquoi ben vous le voyez tous
dans l'actualité on attend l'eau pendant
6 mois et puis le jour où elle arrive on
a des gros orages et là il y a des
inondations et des destructions des
décès etc donc les barrages servent
aussi à réguler un petit peu les
inondations et en fait quand on a une
grosse arrivée d'eau si c'est pas prévu
en amont mais les barrages font ce qu'on
appelle lâcher d'eau et donc il lance
dans la vallée de grosses quantité d'eau
donc si l'inondation qui arrive en amont
du barrage n'est pas très importante le
lâcher d'eau suffit mais des fois ça
suffit pas et là c'est la prévision
catastrophique qui s'annonce donc le but
c'est aussi voilà sur un problème qui
est au départ un problème d'alimentation
des d'irrigation peut aussi se
transformer en un problème de sécurité
et finalement
bah c'est la même chose gérer l'eau la
molécule d'eau qui est stockée qui va
arriver et qui va partir mais finalement
c'est la même
consistance technologique et
scientifique sauf qu'on va là traiter on
va traiter l'information de façon
différenciée par rapport à la
problématique à gérer et souvent on va
se retrouver à avoir tous ces paramètres
en géré en même temps et dans
l'actualité on voit souvent que les
problèmes arrivent quand on est un petit
peu sur sur le le sujet qui n'est pas
tout à fait traité qui est plutôt traité
par un autre et pas pas suffisamment par
le précédent et notre rôle dans cette
dans cette application là et dans cette
approche a été vraiment de prévoir toute
la chaîne de valeur de manière à boucher
l'aimant et donc avoir du recul de la
remise en question sur les processus et
donc d'innover aussi par la remise en
question des processus qui est qui ont
été mis à notre à notre portée
ce troisième exemple mais va nous faire
voyager on va partir à Madagascar
la problématique sur Madagascar qui est
un pays qui produit beaucoup de riz
c'est un pays qui effectivement beaucoup
de capacités sur le riz mais qui doit
améliorer son fonctionnement en termes
de production mais aussi en termes de
filières résolve
le gouvernement malgache nous a
sollicité pour nous pour se poser pour
se poser la question avec nous comment
pourrait-on faire avec les technologies
d'aujourd'hui pour garantir une
structuration de la filière riz à long
terme et pour le bénéfice de tous les
acteurs de la filière en partant par
l'agriculteur le riziculteur qui a des
problématiques de revenus deux quantités
de production de maladies etc donc lui
fournir des éléments qui lui permettent
d'améliorer son processus de production
et en même temps à l'autre bout de la
chaîne le financier qui va chercher à
exporter ces données là pour donner de
la richesse au pays et de l'activité à
la filière risicole donc on a construit
une plateforme donc rien d'innovant dans
une plateforme sur Internet on utilise
tous tous les jours par contre le
l'innovation et le challenge qui était à
relever c'était de mettre des acteurs
qui n'ont rien à voir entre eux de des
gens de l'éducation les producteurs des
financiers des décisions des décideurs
politiques pour leur faire parler un
langage commun leur fournir des éléments
spécifiques à leurs besoins à partir de
la même donnée qui est la donnée riz qui
elle est universelle pour leur pays le
risque et le riz mais voilà avoir
vraiment une des outils qui leur permet
de travailler de manière individuelle ou
en tout cas dans un secteur d'activité
donnée tout en ayant une logique
complète sur la sur la filière RIP
puisque le riz il faut le planter il
pousse à un moment donné on leur récolte
et après il va être mangé ou être
exporté etc donc on voit bien qu'il y a
une logique dans tout ça et donc pour
faire cette proposition cette cette
apport de valeur et cette innovation on
s'est vraiment posé la question de la
vie de ce grain de riz
du moment où on le plante jusqu'à sa
consommation finale et à quel endroit
pour proposer effectivement une approche
extrêmement globale et transverse tout
en ayant une individualisation des
problématiques effectivement ça c'est un
rôle d'assemblure et finalement de
compréhension de tous les acteurs autour
de la filière de la plateforme qui nous
ont permis d'arriver sur une sur une
valeur ajoutée extrêmement importante
qui permet aujourd'hui à la filière
malgache de ce structurer durablement et
de et de relever surtout un défi pour
eux qui était la sécurité alimentaire de
leur population
finalement au travers de ces exemples
on a vu
l'innovation pouvait se cacher là où on
l'entendait pas forcément
qu'effectivement l'innovation est à
différents degrés
et donc ce que je voulais vraiment vous
faire toucher du doigt c'est qu'en fait
l'innovation n'est pas quelque chose que
l'on apprend on peut l'améliorer mais
c'est plus une posture c'est plus une
capacité à remettre en question ce qui
existe à remettre en question des
processus et pas forcément à sortir un
nouveau satellite ou même si ça me fait
partie mais elle est un petit peu
partout et en fait chacun de vous ici
présent et dans le monde être capable de
faire de l'innovation chaque fois que
vous allez vous poser une question mais
ça ça fonctionne pas bien je ferai
plutôt comme ça mais vous êtes déjà dans
le processus d'innovation en fait c'est
vraiment une posture et un état d'esprit
plus que réellement une formation
diplômante ou un métier particulier donc
je pense que vous aurez tous compris que
vous faites déjà tous partis de
l'innovation avec nous ici aujourd'hui